I want to take you back for a second
2004 taking me back 2003 or 2004 what
would you tell that guy now what would I
tell that guy now you have no idea just
wait
that year in the grand scheme of years
ah maybe we've just continued to have
that feeling and that those things as I
said were things that continued to
happen you know over the years and so I
was very when I see that back bumper
plucking up perplexing in there you know
because it can be you know so it was a
pretty good assessment of the time and
it's it's continued so I'm very very
happy about that you're three days away
from a dream that you've had for a long
time
biggest gig in the game right biggest
gig in the game have you prepared for it
and how is it different because you play
stadiums all the time you know it is it
actually is very different the
preparation process is different for
everybody I mean I am sure my process
and our process is different than
anybody else's but it's been kind of
almost like a study in performance and a
study in other aspects outside aspects
who have you studied just I've been I've
watched
I've watched every single halftime show
there there has been mm-hmm
just to get inspiration and to see what
people did and I remember a lot of them
but sure you know just to go back and
revisit some of my favorite ones and
especially the rock bands and especially
the stuff like you know the prints one
which is legendary and Tom Petty and the
stones and Springsteen and you know all
the ball of artists all the bands that I
feel like we are most kind of connected
with musically and you know it's been
it's been amazing and then and then
there's other side of it which is you
know preparing yourself physically you
know for the whole thing - so I've been
treating it like I'm about to play in
the Super Bowl myself working out a lot
yeah even taking care of myself for the
past 30 days how do you prepare for the
spectacle of it all you're not a dam I
mean I'm not a dancer either but you're
not a dancer so no how do you prepare to
make this a spectacle this is kind of
answer to every question when it comes
to the Super Bowl and marine fires
involvement in it the music you know
that the spectacle is the music the way
that we speak is through the music and
the way that we emot-- in and perform is
through the music so yeah I think that
this is being you know the curation I
guess of the show and putting it
together in that whole process
figuring out what we're gonna do how
we're gonna do it
that is all being centered around the
music and so to me you know where there
usually is a little more fanfare and
there's a lot more there are dancers and
there are I guess bells and whistles
there's the answer
yeah we just kind of wanted to bring it
back to a time when it was a little more
simple when when the shows were the
highlight the focus was the the
connection to the songs and to me that's
what always that that's why we're still
here that's why that owes me in 2004 and
and that's I think why we're here at
2019 this performance there has been
controversy around us playing this
performance and desert what with just a
little what would into your decision to
play the Super Bowl halftime show when
you look back on every single Super Bowl
halftime show hmm it's this like
insatiable urge to to hate a little bit
I'm not in the right profession if I
can't handle a little bit of controversy
it's what it is we expected it you'd
like to move on from it and like I said
earlier speak through them use the music
did you talk to anybody before you made
the decision maybe I did I spoke to many
people but most importantly though when
I silenced all the noise listen to
myself and made my decision based upon
how I felt about it all why'd you guys
cancel this press conference the NFL
canceled the press conference you'll
have to sleep with them
has this changed the way you go about
this performance I could say yes and no
because honestly I think that being in a
band and being an artist in publicly
appearing and performing you have to
take into account all of the things are
surrounding it in that case it's no
different than any other concert so no
you know I think we put together a show
based upon the things that we had
collected over the last 20 years and
most recently I think we just wanted to
make sure that we were able to speak
once again through the music mm-hmm and
so yes absolutely once we processed all
of these things and look it took a lot
of looking inward it took a lot of
introspection and I thought to myself
what's my greatest tool you know what's
what's the thing that I can use to
express myself and how the bank in it
what's the best way for the band to
express themselves and how are we going
to do it this year what do we owe
ourselves what do we owe the people
and that's what we did and I'm beyond
proud of the finished product and I've
never been more excited in my entire
life to present this to the people
because I believe that it's truly a
reflection of all of us having known you
for a while I know you're not someone
who would take this decision lightly and
looking at know the past people you've
collaborated I I'm assuming that when
you say you looked inside you looked
inside hard I did absolutely 100% I will
never sit here and deny that I think
that to have not done that would have
been deeply irresponsible so I did no
one thought about it more than I did no
one put more thought and love into this
and I've been having a big boy out there
um Atlanta zone Atlanta baby what does
that mean to you to have him as part of
the show and and could that mean also
because people are asking could that
mean that we will hear Outkast music or
an Outkast were Union I cannot divulge
the details on that level because that
would be spoiling it you don't wanna do
that
Big Boi is my dude he's been incredible
he is Atlanta I mean when I think about
music and I think about the Atlanta
scene and I think of all these guys like
he is just such an incredible I mean
even yesterday walking out start dress
rehearsals you know the reaction he
embodies so much of where we are mm-hmm
and to mete out that especially this
year but I mean every be a nice thing
every year to pay homage musically to
your geographical location is a
beautiful thing and he epitomizes music
in this part of the country so man
there's no no more perfect well suited
human being now you have Travis Scott
one of the young bucks young man young
Travis Scott he's being incredible to
man he's great you know it's one of
those things where so much of what we do
and a lot of the things ways in which we
collaborate with other artists involves
hip-hop I mean from from day one to be
honest with you like you know that's the
funny thing about our band is that we're
on the surface we've always been a rock
band and maybe we've been tchard into
other parts of music and things that
have interested interested us but
whenever anybody asked me you know how
did it all begin
especially with maroon 5 peace 100% this
shift of focus into R&B and hip-hop and
all this great stuff that was happening
in
1999 2000 2001 and all these great all
these great incredible artists and
producers and writers emerging and you
know that was the game that we wanted to
be up in and it was a little bit
audacious because for obvious reasons
but that was every album that we made
was always our greatest attempt at
emulating our heroes in rock and roll
but also in hip hop around via - so
Travis dr. Travis Travis is he is it
right now he's the one you know it's
like this is a moment for him and we
love what he does obviously we love what
he represents because we love having
there be a presence that there this is
the the show that's gonna have the
biggest hip hop presence that there has
ever been on the show I mean I can't
look back and find that to have been the
case before so he's it he's the man
right now and he comes in hot we all
your ladies the most important ladies in
your life yeah here yeah do they have
any idea - there's no way your kids can
understand the importance of this moment
okay they know they're too little but
you know I think that in a little little
little kids that they're gonna stay home
it's a little bit of a fiasco out here
it's a little crazy
mm-hmm we're gonna keep them home my
wife will be out here though very person
which can be nice but they gotta watch
on TV I'm gonna wear daddy bracelets so
they can see that I'm representing them
well so they have knowing they'll always
have that and they get to watch on TV
I'm sure they'd prefer that too yeah
chaos yeah all right get rid of that
chaos yeah this is also when we talked
about this being an important dream for
you and now this dream comes to fruition
and you think about someone who helped
you make that dream was Jordan hmm
you're a former manager Jordan Felton
it's been almost a year since he passed
away tragically but what does it mean it
will you think of him when you walk up
on that stage yeah of course I will
I'm here because of me and I'm here
because of the band but I'm here because
of Jordan this was our thing you know
this was what we wanted so of course you
know and ultimately when looking at all
this stuff and and meeting him and
listening for him mm-hm
you know that that was a huge factor in
all of this and accepting this challenge
and a challenge it has been
obviously but at the end of the day I
know what he would have wanted me to do
and I know how he would have wanted me
to do it and so it's got me this far you
know so I feel like he's always with me
somehow he's there he's there oh he's
there girls like you um is a really an
anthem in a way and it's a beautiful
song but it's also a video that seemed
like it was the perfect video at the
perfect time with everything going on in
our country with me too and how will you
incorporate that and would we see any of
those folks pop up because you had a lot
of famous faces in that video that video
was really one of the most amazing
projects I think I've ever been a part
of in my life it was exciting it was
scary it was you know it was all these
different emotions when you want I cope
when I think back about the process yeah
the song meant a lot to a lot of people
and and I thought that it was important
for maroon 5 to do something that you'd
think would be done more often which is
celebrate women that's a beautiful thing
we love the life that it gave the song
beyond just to just the silly pop song
it kind of gathered a new meaning you
know from the video and and of course I
can answer your question about people
being being there or not but that's a
lot of people trust me just wrangling
that many people for the video in
general was tough enough so I you know I
can't I can't promise that every single
person will be there for the Superbowl
but having that song as part of our
repertoire is one of those great things
you always get to have you know like you
always get to play that song that
reminds women about how powerful they
are and makes everybody feel good at the
same time mm-hmm it's really special and
so that's what the song means now and
it's great to be playing potentially
playing the song at the Super Bowl
because that's that's what it does
that's that's that's the feeling that it
produces and so we're very happy to have
a song that means that to so many people
especially to so many women has been
hard to make the choice of what you know
what's out given this task to whittle
away at 20 years of music and live
concert it's you know performing onto
her and putting on the best shows within
a 90 minute context or alone and they're
like okay oh now I got truncate all that
I got put it in 12 and a half 13
and you're like alright so that whole
process has been aside from the
spiritual process the the physical
process of putting it all together has
been intense and and so difficult you
know because you want to make sure you
give everybody this small version of
what you do live so you have to be kind
of true to that and it's man I'll tell
you we've had a lot of hits and we've
been very lucky but too many who's the
final decision-maker final decision you
know I was a humongous part of the
process I put I put the show together
and and you know the band obviously
always we're always talking about it at
least I'm always asking and they're
always giving me things and we're always
being a band that's that that process
never never stops but you know I think
that bands quickly realize in order to
survive you got to have a have a
ringleader I have a mayor somebody yeah
sometimes they sometimes a dictator they
say sometimes but yeah so so they trust
me and I trust them and so I've been at
the helm I've been at the helm of this
thing and putting it together and put
the guests as well it's been it's been a
process to the people who now as you
prepare for this and you say just let
the music speak yes but there are people
out there who want to hear from you I
mean we are we're in Atlanta we're so
close to where dr. King was born and
raised what do you say to the folks who
say that they just want to be heard and
how will your performance be they will
be it's all I want to say because I
don't want to spoil anything and once
again I'd like to think that people know
where I stand as a human being after two
decades of doing this I'm not a speaker
I'm not a public speaker I do speak but
it's through the music you know my
life's work and what I've put out into
the universe has been positive and
hopefully inspiring and you know it's
funny because people will reach out and
say hey you know I was sick and or I had
went through this breakup or I went
through this life this traumatic life
experience let's say your music helped
me thank you and there's no more
meaningful interaction as far as music
is concerned of what we do within that
right so what I would say is you know
look we're gonna keep doing what we're
doing hopefully without becoming
politicians and continuing to use the
one voice we know how to use properly
right to make people understand we got
you got you
[Music]